qui avec d'autres à distribuer toutes
ces années des milliards aux banques et
fermer des maternités ou des écoles pour
prétendument épargner entre guillemets
l'argent public
oui que cette république est bien
malmené que les années que nous venons
de traverser l'on déformé par l'hyper
présidentialisation et l'effacement du
parlement par des modes de scrutin qui
tronquent la réalité politique de notre
pays
déformé par un exercice inique du
pouvoir soumis à la loi du marché et de
la finance
un peu ta femme et l'autre impunément
cria l'enragé jacques roux à la tribune
de la convention le 25 juin 1793 et je
suis parmi vous avec vous ce soir c'est
si je suis parmi vous avec vous ce soir
c'est bien sûr pour rendre hommage aux
femmes et aux hommes et à leurs
représentants qui lie à 220 ans
décrétèrent le peuple souverain est seul
maître de son destin
mais aussi parce que sans cet
anniversaire est plus que jamais
d'actualité
oui le temps est venu de décréter à
nouveau le salut commun la vème
république dans laquelle nous vivons est
à bout de souffle
elle ressemble de plus en plus à une
sorte de monarchie déguisé clandestine
elle ressemble plus à sac à cette
caricature de la république qu'à la
république de chaque français que chaque
femme et homme qui a choisi notre nation
pour s'établir porte dans son coeur et
qui garantit l'égalité des citoyens
devant la loi qui garantit les droits
fondamentaux et leur accueil et leur
égalité d'accès à tous
la première loi sociale et celle qui
garantit à tous les membres de la
société les moyens d'exister toutes les
autres lois sont subordonnés à celle là
ainsi parlait robespierre le 2 décembre
c'est pourquoi quel que soit notre
engagement philosophiques ou politiques
ce qui nous réunit nous rassemble ici
si nous sommes présents c'est parce que
la république fondent notre engagement
constant pour la justice
l'égalité la liberté et la fraternité
contre elle les forces qui s'accrochent
à leurs privilèges et qui en veulent
toujours plus sont mobilisés et il faut
le reconnaître elles ont un certain
talent particulier pour instaurer la
peur la confusion la division la
république ne fut pas décréter elle fut
acquise dans le mouvement de l'histoire
au coeur de la grande révolution
française
jaurès a écrit par l'eau dans son
histoire socialiste de la révolution
française à propos de cette naissance
c'était une sublime nouveautés du monde
et il décrivait ce moment en ces mots il
y avait eu avant des républiques
aristocratique ou fondée sur le travail
des esclaves
il y avait eu des républiques barbares
courte associations militaires ou le
courage suscitait et désignait les chefs
il y avait de petites république
oligarchique comme celle des cantons
suisses il y avait la république des
eyzies guide des exilés des proscrits
celle que sur le sol vierge de
l'amérique où il n'y avait aucune racine
de monarchie formèrent les descendants
de puritains mais qu'un grand est vaste
au peuple policé et riche chargé de dix
siècles d'histoire qui avait grandi avec
la monarchie et qui hier encore à la
veille de ce geste fondateur la jugeait
nécessaire même à la révolution que ce
peuple où il n'y avait pas d'esclaves où
il n'y avait plus de serre et où depuis
le 10 août où les citoyens étaient égaux
s'éleva à la république et qu'ils
devront et qu'il devint vraiment tout
entier dans tous ces éléments un peuple
de roi voilà en effet la grande
nouveauté est la grande audace voilà ce
que disait jaurès
excusez moi je vais essayer là aussi au
milieu de l'appui de retrouver mon petit
papier ça vient
voilà l'esprit que nous célébrons
aujourd'hui le bicentenaire de la
république il y a vingt ans cela a été
rappelé par michel biard coïncidait avec
le référendum sur le traité de
maastricht et malheureusement
probablement à cause de cela aussi comme
il le rappelait qui se souvient de ce
bicentenaire qui était pourtant une date
majeure pour notre république et bien
d'une certaine manière ces vingt
dernières années on comptait et compte
encore dans la bataille que nous
poursuivons pour qu'advienne toujours et
rhône est toujours la république et ses
droits fondamentaux
ce n'est pas une bataille entre l'europe
et les nations
c'est une bataille entre notre peuple
les peuples européens
hello log et l'oligarchie financière qui
cherche à toujours maintenir ses
privilèges que de bataille depuis qu'ils
continuent aujourd'hui contre ceux qui
veulent confisquer la souveraineté de
notre peuple à l'aristocratie nobiliaire
d'hier a succédé une aristocratie
financière qui voit aujourd'hui dans
toute dépense publique de solidarité un
manque-à-gagner insupportable
pourquoi 200 warrants deux cent vingt
ans après la république après la
première république quand il y a tant de
richesses la partager avec ceux qui sont
les plus nombreux et qui les ont
produites lors reste si insupportable
que cherchent ces forces qui se battent
bec et ongles pour leur monde
un libéral herbert spencer a écrit dont
le droit d'ignorer l'état en 1851 la
fonction du libéralisme dans le passé a
été de mettre en est une limite au
pouvoir des rois
la fonction du vrai libéralisme
écrivait-il dans l'avenir sera de
limiter le pouvoir des parlements voilà
que nous y sommes
la république appelle à un nouvel âge
alors que les libéraux eux veulent
continuer à se passer des parlements les
républicains nous nous voulons au
contraire arracher des droits et des
poufs
art nouveau pour les citoyens et pour
les salariés dans les entreprises et
dans les institutions
parce que là est le vrai pouvoir
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne voient d'olive les
libéraux qui ne voient de liberté que
dans la circulation des flux financiers
et les pouvoirs du capital veulent
démolir tous les droits sociaux le code
et la durée légale du travail des pc une
bonne fois pour toutes
les services publics s'approprier tout
ce qui peut se vendre et être
rentabilisé la santé l'énergie et le
reste
qu'importe qu'on fasse vivent les
peuples sous l'urgence et la
précipitation le manquer les besoins
constants l'injustice et la concurrence
la compétition et les aliénations la
république française mépriser celle au
peuple et la nation de france qu'on
méprise et que pour cela on invoque la
nécessité européenne est une insulte à
l'intelligence de notre peuple et à
celle de tous les peuples d'europe qui
veulent voir advenir la solidarité et
les droits sociaux pour tous ce jour 21
septembre est devenu aussi au long des
siècles qui nous séparent de valmy et de
la naissance de la république une
journée mondiale de la paix il ne peut y
avoir pour les républicains que nous
sommes pour les démocrates que nous
sommes de plus belle association que
celles de la république et de la paix du
désarmement et de la coopération entre
les peuples
lorsque les français firent leur
révolution les noblesse de robe salière
pour la mettre en échec
oui la violence peut être présente dans
une révolution mais que de violence
déployée lorsque les aristocrates pour
protéger leurs privilèges déclenchèrent
la guerre et la répandirent en europe et
nous savons trop bien aujourd'hui que
ces processus ne sont pas éradiquées et
qu'ils peuvent ressurgir et qu ils
ressurgissent malheureusement trop
souvent aujourd'hui les aristocrates
mène les nouveaux aristocrates mène une
nouvelle hier les institutions
financières les banques l'estran
transnationales ont imposé la guerre
économique et nous ne voulons pas de ce
de cela ils cherchent eux mêmes
on le voit malheureusement ces jours ci
à promouvoir le choc des civils
a sion pour pour ben d'une certaine
manière faire perdurer dans la division
l'iniquité de l'ordre capitaliste
fidèle à la république qui mérite plus
que jamais une seconde jeunesse que nous
nommons sixième république nous le ton
contre le pouvoir de l'argent qui
cassent et jette les hommes entre eux
nous luttons pour une république des
droits de l'homme de la femme de
l'enfant et du citoyen nous luttons pour
cette république la conjuration des
esgaulx un combat démocratique sans
autre arme que la force de conviction
le rassemblement l'imagination et
l'élaboration il n'ya pas les uns qui
pensent et les autres qui obéissent même
aux meilleurs d'entre nous la république
et cette invention de l'inconnu ce
courage commun cette force collective où
l'homme libre compte à part entière où
il choisit de faire société
car la solidarité nous unit est fait de
chacun d'entre nous un être pleinement
humain
ce combat a sans doute connu depuis la
première république plusieurs naissances
il faut d'une certaine manière la faire
renaître ce combat pour nous n'a pas de
fin merci
vive la république et merci d'avoir tenu
le temps j'appelle jean luc mélenchon
qui vient maintenant pareil égalité du
temps de parole à toi nous verrons bien
comment ces valu cette égalité
merci à la société des études
robespierristes de nous donner
l'occasion de pratiquer ce qu'un
justement et si cruellement les
autorités ne pratique plus la
célébration de la proclamation de notre
république il ya 220 ans nous sommes
allés nous recueillir devant l'unique
monument où l'on aperçoit la silhouette
notre libérateur
maximilien robespierre nous ne sommes
pas venus commémorer
nous sommes venus célébrer nous ne
sommes pas venus nous souvenir
nous sommes venus nous inspirait la
république nous appellent et cet appel
retentit de bien des façons d'abord
peut-être à l'évocation des grands
moments de notre histoire où l'idée
devenue chère au lead est devenu être
humain où l'idée est devenue
institutions et où ce qu avait pensé
jean jacques s'est transformé en une
réalité dont la dynamique n'a pas fini
d'embarrasser le monde
ce 20 septembre à l'aube tandis que les
estafettes sont le lien avec nos armes
et paris d'or à la veille de la tenue de
la convention nationale
paris d'or et pourtant il pleut
comme aujourd'hui il pleut
interminablement depuis juillet la
patrie a été déclarée en danger leroy
fuyard a été rattrapé mais c'est partout
les complots les trahisons
nous sommes envahis et les frontières
ont été passés verdun a été livré par
les officiers royalistes beaucaire a
préféré se suicider plutôt que
d'accepter de rendre la place il pleut
il pleut tout semblait perdu
c'est l'heure des caractères aval ni il
pleut voilà quinze jours qu'il pleut
l'armée d'invasion dinis les se traîne
comme une limace dans la craie et de
l'est de la france à 3 heures du matin
les prussiens ont commencé à se mettre
en mouvement pour se tourner du côté de
la colline de valmy où sont les nôtres
le général kellerman est arrivé la
veille et il a choisi cette position
pour tenir en face de l'invasion
il y à la branche ficc celui qui a
occupé verdun et annoncé qu'il exigeait
le retour des nobles de l'église et de
leurs privilèges
ce qui fut immédiatement entendu et bien
compris aussitôt les paysans en garder
par devers eux toutes les nourritures
qui pouvait servir à l'armée
d'occupation et se poster tout le long
du trajet attendant l'occasion de faire
un mauvais sort à ceux qui venaient
régler leurs comptes avec nous bon je
suis qui avait adressé à la population
de paris se manifestent provocateur où
il prétendait tirer une vengeance
exemple
l'air si l'on ne rétablirait pas
immédiatement le roi et les nobles dans
leurs prérogatives
les nôtres ils sont sur cette colline ce
sont les fédérer venue d'abord à paris
députés bretons qui ont fondé le club
des jacobins provençaux parisien membres
des gardes nationales quelques éléments
de l'ancienne armée d'ancien régime
et puis venus par centaines les membres
des sections parisiennes
au point qu'on ne sait où les mettre on
les intercepts en route on t'a je leur
demander de ne pas aller encombrer les
fils de nos armées il pleut à 7 heures
du matin les prussiens émergent de la
brume la canonnade est commencé elle va
durer toute la journée les nôtres ce
sont jean simples artisans ouvriers et
paysans ils doivent tenir des heures et
des heures et ya rien de pire que de
tenir en ligne sous la canonnade 40000
boulet vont être tirés ce jour-là il est
11 heures
regardons-nous les troupes
révolutionnaires c'est ce peuple mais
c'est aussi une troupe à
internationaliste on y compte des
allemands des irlandais des liégeois
dans nos rangs il ya latino américains
il est général de nos armées c'est
miranda qui tient bon sous la mitraille
il sera ensuite l'un des premiers
libertador avec simon bolivar et l'élan
commencé sur la colline continue
aujourd'hui là bas dans les caraïbes
le 20 septembre à 11 heures
l'ennemi se met en colonnes et les
nôtres de même kellerman fait passer la
consigne
il ne faut pas tirer attendre on recevra
à la baïonnette la baïonnette et voilà
nos paysans
nos braves artisans les doigts engourdis
par le froid de ce jour qui ne se
réchauffe pas qu'ils installent les
baïonnettes à la pointe des fusils en
face si nous sommes internationaliste en
face il y à 26000 traîtres à la patrie
officiers royalistes émigrés fiscaux et
des privilèges de plus deux sortent
toujours les mêmes qui n'ont jamais eu
d'autre patrie que leurs privilèges ni
d'autres conviction que leurs préjugés
de caste et de classe contre la liberté
du peuple et sa souveraineté
la canonnade continue et voici le moment
décisif
mich les raconte il y eut un moment de
silence la fumée se dissipait les
prussiens et est descendu et franchissez
l'espace intermédiaire avec la gravité
d'une vieille harnais et il allait
monter au français branche ficc alors
dirigée alors ni a été vite un spectacle
surprenant extraordinaire à l'exemple de
kellermann tous les français ayant leur
chapeau à la pointe des sabres des épées
des baïonnettes avait poussé un grand
cri
ce cri de 30000 hommes remplissait toute
la vallée c'était comme un cri de joie
mais étonnamment prolonger et ils ne
dura guère moins d'un quart d'heure fini
il recommençait toujours avec plus de
force
la terre en tremblait c'était vive la
nation
toute l'armée des auteurs du moulin
raconte jean jaurès jusqu'en bas des
pentes crie vive la nation et tous ceux
qui depuis trois ans contenaient ce mot
il y avait accumulé en soi d'énergie
radieux se communique à tous les coeurs
c'est fini le cauchemar du passé se
dissiper et de même que sous
l'ébranlement de la canonnade le ciel de
valny d'abord chargé de nuées
s'éclaircit s'élève et s'illumine
de même toutes les ombres du doute et de
la crainte sont dissipés en un instant
le ressort de l'armée prussienne et
brisé
c'est elle qui bat en retraite pendant
que l'artillerie révolutionnaire déchire
ses rangs il peut il peut toujours plus
à 6 heures une pluie torrentielle s'abat
sur les troupes
le roi de prusse et battre la retraite
nous avons vaincu
j'aurais sera compte gouttes
le puissant et clair poète qui avait
accompagné l'armée prussienne marque a
tout de suite la grandeur de cet
événement que 10 de ce jour et de ce
lieu date une ère nouvelle dans
l'histoire du monde
jaurès complète c'était le 20 septembre
le même jour à paris la convention
nationale à l'ouvert sa première séance
au dessus il rit elle allait voter
l'abolition de la royauté on appris la
nouvelle de valmy on rapporte qu alors
des travaux et des tribunes le même qui
roule à de nouveaux vive la nation vive
la nation
de quelle nation parlons nous là la
france n'avait pas ses frontières sur la
colline les bretons qui tenait bon
parlaient entre eux je l'imaginé dans la
peur l angoisse
l'une de leurs cinq landes les
provençaux devait parler la belle langue
occitane ceux de la région parisienne le
français ainsi ils ne parlaient pas la
même langue il ne jurait pas le même
dieu ils n'avaient pas les mêmes unités
poids deux mesures car tout cela c'est
la révolution et la liberté qu'il a
rendu possible la nation que nous avons
constitué n'a jamais été une nation
ethnique ce qui fait sens dans la
révolution et dans la république que
nous avons créé ce n'est pas à la
continuité trompeuse des lieux et des
personnages c'est la rupture le grand
bouleversement qui a battu dans seul pan
tout l'ordre ancien pour créer non
seulement un est à nouveau mais osons le
dire une humanité nouvelle fondée sur la
liberté l'égalité et la fraternité
quelle que soit la langue que l'on parle
quel que soit son genre et la couleur de
sa peau voilà quelle est la république
française une et indivisible non du fait
de ses frontières
mais de ce seul fait que son peuple est
un et indivisible puisqu'il a partout
les mêmes droits et que la loi est en
voté par tous
elle s'applique à tous de la même
manière puissant ou misérable liberté
égalité qu'il s'agit de reconquérir
la république n'a pas fondé le droit du
peuple français
la révolution n'a pas été fait pour les
français
elle a été faite pour des droits humains
applicable à toute personne humaine la
république française n'est pas
occidental
elle est aussi universaliste l'été ses
premières troupes et qu'elle leur est
alors même qu'elle est présente dans
tous les océans du monde et que sa plus
longue frontière extérieure par la
guyane est avec le brésil la république
n'est pas un régime neutre c'est un
régime qui proclame l'égalité la liberté
la fraternité contre toutes les
évidences de la nature et des
différences de privilèges liés à la
naissance
et c'est parce que la france est déchiré
d'inégalités travail et d'absurde
xénophobie de racisme c'est imbécile
mais peut-il y en avoir un autre qu'il
faut la refonder et que ce nouveau grand
peuple qui est parmi nous formé comme
chaque fois de la nouvelle génération
doit redéfinir sa règle commune or
définissant sa constitution c'est bien
pourquoi l'histoire de la révolution a
toujours été controversé
c'est bien pourquoi encore aujourd'hui
elle fait l'objet de tant de calomnies
on trouve tant de bonnes est intéressé
pour aller faire l'apologie du roi ce
traître qui paraissait si banal dans son
pouvoir lui qui s'intéressait après les
frasques de louis 15 à la serrurerie et
à l'éducation de ses enfants comme tout
un chacun et la reine si légère si free
bruits qui jouait à la bergère
ces deux-là conspiraient contre la
patrie appelé l'invasion pour établir
leurs privilèges payer des
parlementaires et des journalistes pour
répandre leurs complots et c'est après
tout cela qu'on trouve encore des films
des livres des bandes dessinées pour
jeter des grosses larmes sur nos
oppresseurs
tandis qu'on aurait pour ceux qui nous
ont libérés que des mépris et des
caricatures
à commencer par celles qui sont faites
contre maximilien robespierre dont nous
nous honorons de dire qu'il est un
exemple et une source d'inspiration pour
nous
ce n'est pas pour rien que la révolution
a été traîné dans la boue partout ce
dans tous les âges qui avait pour
objectif premier de mettre en cause la
liberté l'égalité ainsi quand mussolini
dit le fascisme s'oppose à tout les
abstractions individualiste à fondement
matérialiste c'est pourquoi il s'oppose
à toutes les utopies et innovations
jacobine ainsi qu en goebbels 10 l'an 10
789 sera rayé de l'histoire ainsi quand
jean françois copé dit il y a en france
une tentation de la nuit du 4 août dont
il faut se débarrasser ainsi quand jean
françois copé dit le ca ira n'est plus
d'époque les temps sont passés ainsi
quand il dit la révolution a fait
beaucoup de mal et à fracturer la
société elle a désappris aux français le
goût de l'effort
chacun depuis deux siècles et 20 ans a
choisi son camp en vain chercherait-il à
faire croire que la révolution elle
finie elle ne fait que commencer
aussi longtemps que son oeuvre
égalitaire n'est pas achevé l'intuition
révolutionnaire et confirmer qu'il n'y a
qu'un seul écosystème compatibles avec
la vie humaine il ya donc un intérêt
général humains comme l'avait proclamé
jean jacques rousseau
nous n'avons d'autre moyen de le
connaître que par notre intelligence
raison pour laquelle il nous faut être
éduqués librement gratuitement et
laïquement raison pour laquelle nous
devons être égaux
car on ne peut délibérer librement sous
la domination d'un autre raison pour
laquelle il nous faut nous prononcer non
pas sur ce que nous croyons bon pour
nous mêmes ce qui suffit en démocratie
mais pour ce qui est bon pour tous ceux
qui l exigence de la république
célébrez célébrer inspirez vous pensez
comme l'a dit victor hugo ce qui est le
fond de cette affaire
célébrer s'est préparé de grands
événements entendez le bruit terrible de
la roue de l'histoire qui s'est remise
en mouvement quand dans toute l'europe
de nouveau se coalisent contre la
liberté et contre la démocratie
les puissants qui par des traités inepte
qui seront rechargées au prix de quelle
douleur par les peuples prétendre
décider en lieu et place du souverain
qui est pour toujours le peuple lui même
entendez la grande roue de l'histoire
lorsque les privilèges de se maintenir
de force et que c'est par l'intimidation
que l'on condamne en martyr nos frères
et nos soeurs grecs espagnols portugais
et que l'on prétend subjugué la volonté
nationale et l'intérêt général en nous
condamnant à renoncer à tout ce qui a
fait notre grandeur c'est à dire le
partage l'éducation le soin et tout ce
qui avait été pressenti d'abord par nos
libérateurs de 1789
nos armées de 1792 dans la peur et
langlois ce de cette pluie sans fin sur
la commune de valmy au nous avons vaincu